that's Jodie Sweetin paying tribute to
full house on the season 22 premiere of
Dancing with the Stars
the actress delivered a strong debut
performance dancing the tango with her
partner Keo mutts ma
Jodie's moves earned her a total of 20 a
solid score for the 34 year old actress
but when it came time for fellow TV star
Mischa Barton to tango with her partner
artemchik Vince said it wasn't exactly
smooth sailing
Carrie Ann Inaba pries the
thirty-year-olds fearlessness but Len
Goodman and Bruno Tonioli were a bit
more direct with their critiques if not
in my nature to be now speak but that
wasn't a dance that was walking you have
to work on your core everything comes
from here if not the looks look slightly
sedated
Barton's tango scored 16 the third
lowest score of the night but she did
receive praise from a very special OC
co-star we're still friends right rachel
bilson posted this screenshot to
Instagram Monday night writing got to
give it up for Misha amazing takes balls
get it girl